>> Sean: ANDREW McCARTHY HAS
A NEW COLUMN OUT TODAY AND IT'S
TITLED "DEMOCRATS, COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THE FBI INVESTIGATION OR
ABSURD."
HE JOINS US NOW, FOX NEWS LEGAL
ANALYST AT GREGG JARRETT, CHIEF
COUNSEL FOR THE JUDICIAL CRISIS
NETWORK.
CARRIE SEVERINO.
TO ME, ANDY, FROM THE BEGINNING
IT WAS, OKAY.
THESE ARE THE ALLEGATIONS.
NOW YOU ASK THE PEOPLE AND THEY
SAID IN EVERY CASE THAT THERE
WERE PEOPLE THAT COULD
CORROBORATE THIS.
UNLESS PEOPLE CHANGE THEIR MIND,
REMEMBER UNDER PENALTY OF A
FELONY, THEY ARE GOING TO ADMIT
THEY COMMITTED A FELONY AND
CHANGE THEIR STORY.
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT
DELAY FROM THE VERY BEGINNING,
THAT'S ALL IT'S BEEN ABOUT.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT THEY
WERE NOT ABLE TO CORROBORATE
THOSE ALLEGATIONS.
I THINK THOSE ALLEGATIONS IN A
NORMAL PROCESS, HE WOULD HAVE
NEVER HEARD OF THEM, BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THE SENATE HAS TO BET
THOSE KINDS OF CLAIMS WHERE
PEOPLE SAY THEY WANT TO REMAIN
CONFIDENTIAL AND IF THEY CAN GO
INTO THE SORT OF THING.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS WAS EVER
ABOUT.
THEY WERE RAISING CLAIMS AT THE
LAST MINUTE IN ORDER TO FORCE
DELAY.
AND EVERY DAY THE FBI
INVESTIGATION GOES ON THEY RAISE
NEW QUESTIONS ABOUT THE DEPTH OF
IT.
AND THE WHOLE POINT
TRANSPARENTLY HAS BEEN TO PUSH
THIS BEYOND THEM AND TURNS IN
THE HOPE THAT THEY WERE IN THE
SENATE AND CAN BEAT THEM ON.
>> Sean: AS WE SPEAK, BREAKING
HERE ON FOX, IS ON THE SENATE
FLOOR.
IF HE FILES COAT CLOSURE THAT
WILL TEE UP A FOUR-DAY PROCESS
TO HAVE CONFIRMATION VOTE ON
SATURDAY.
THAT'S IF HE FILES CLOTURE.
WHY WOULD MITCH McCONNELL AT
9:52 P.M. EASTERN TIME BE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR?
>> WE GOT THE FBI REPORT WHICH
IS WHAT EVERYONE WAS WAITING FO
FOR -- SATURDAY WOULD BE THE
EARLIEST, LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE SENATORS THEMSELVES TO
LOOK AT THIS REPORT.
>> Sean: DO YOU KNOW ANYONE
THAT'S TALKED TO MURKOWSKI OR
COLLINS?
>> I KNOW McCONNELL IS TALKING
TO THEM, AND THEY HAD SAID JUST
ALONG THE LINES THAT
SENATOR McCONNELL AND SAID,
GIVE US A WEEK.
I THINK THAT WILL MAKE THEM MORE
COMFORTABLE, GREAT.
BUT WE DIDN'T GET ANYTHING NEW
OUT OF IT.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT THE
REPERCUSSIONS, GREG?
IT'S A DUE PROCESS.
>> IT'S SAD BUT THERE IS NO DUE
PROCESS, THERE IS NO FUNDAMENTAL
FAIRNESS, NO PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE AMONG THE MEDIA AND
DEMOCRATS.
I FIND IT AMAZING NOW THAT THE
VERY INDIVIDUAL DIANNE FEINSTEIN
WHO CAN FEEL THE INFORMATION
INITIALLY NOW IS ATTEMPTING TO
CONCEAL THE FBI REPORT THAT SHE
DEMANDED.
THIS HAS BEEN CAREENING WILDLY
OUT OF CONTROL, AND THE ONLY WAY
TO SLAM THE BRAKES ON THIS
IMMINENT TRAIN WRECK IS TO BE
OPEN AND HONEST AND TRANSPARENT
AND YET, THAT'S NOT WHAT DIANNE
FEINSTEIN WANTS.
WHY?
MAYBE BECAUSE SHE WANTS TO
MISREPRESENT THE CONTENTS OF
THAT REPORT AND APPARENTLY OFFER
NO COOPERATION AND ONLY
REPUTATION OF THE ACCUSATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT.
>> Sean: ANDY, DOES KAVANAUGH
GET CONFIRMED OR DO THE SMEARS
WORK?
>> I THINK HE GETS CONFIRMED.
I SAW YOU SPEAK TO NEWT GINGRICH
TONIGHT AND I THINK HE HAS IT
RIGHT, YOU WILL GET CONFIRMED.
>> I AGREE.
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE LIKE JOE
MANCHIN AND HEITKAMP, THERE'S A
THREE-POINT DIFFERENCE IN THOSE
STATES.
>> Sean: HE WON'T DO IT UNLESS
REPUBLICANS HAVE THE VOTE.
LAST PRODUCTION, GREGG JARRETT?
>> I THINK HE GETS CONFIRMED
THAT HE MAY ACTUALLY GET A
COUPLE DEMOCRATS ON BOARD ONCE
THEY READ THE CONTENTS OF HIS
FBI REPORT THAT APPARENTLY,
THOSE OF US WHO SUFFERED THROUGH